in the Kentucky Derby it's billed as the
fastest two minutes in sports the
Kentucky Derby's history reaches back
more than 140 years the inside the very
first Derby was held in May of 1875 it
was fashioned after England's
Epsom Derby and it took horse-racing in
the Bluegrass State off the streets and
onto the tracks what was going on at the
Epsom Derby was the royal family was
attending the upper-class was attending
they were dressed up the women wearing
gowns and hats the men were in coats and
ties while getting dressed to the nines
is a tradition as old as the race this
year's clothes horses may want to pack a
poncho forecasters say there's a good
chance of rain for today's race we got
out and stopped at the gate we just ran
that hence the newspapers cover up the
head I was just telling my husband I
wish I would have put jeans in my purse
I'm not above doing that this year's
field of twenty horses is wide open
classic Empire is the favorite at four
to one but if there's a sentimental pick
its patch a thirty to one long shot
who's dealing with a disability nothing
in his races or in his training would it
would ever let you know that you know
he's missing an eye the three-year-old
colt lost his left eye just a year ago
but his trainer says it hasn't hurt his
performance on the track none of the
riders ever feel him carrying himself
and he differently and you know even
even in his first start he was behind
horses dirt in his face and I was amazed
at how how well he he had all that as
patch makes just his fourth career start
today a derby veteran will be overcoming
the odds to make his 22nd appearance at
the race Steve Buttle Minh has been
calling the horses to the post with his
bugle since 1996 but during this week's
drawing to determine which stall the
horses will start from Buttle Minh fell
and injured his leg while that might
have been enough to scratch one of the
horses it'll take more to keep Buttle
Minh out
the winner circled it just blows my mind
every year that I get to be the guy that
does this and I just feel very fortunate
and very blessed to do it and what's the
Kentucky Derby without a cocktail the
races signature drink is the mint julep
about 120,000 of them will be poured at
Churchill Downs today nearly one for
every one hundred and forty thousand
people in attendance but to do it right
it needs to be served up in a silver cup
Anthony is a cocktail enthusiast I like
the looks very much I know you'll be
interested to know that there are 1,000
pounds of mint use at the Derby for the
juleps and 60,000 pounds I'm trying to
imagine a thousand pounds of mint can I
just say that I would like the Bugler's
job at the Kentucky Derby that to me
it's pretty sweet I can I just say that
I would like to see patch go home with a
derby crown I know I think you know what
the sentimental favorite all right